good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast I'm your loyal host Jackie
Ashish rice embarking on booze and get
into it get our hands dirty and solve
the world's problems I love the set
thank you it's really fun really toasty
is how we describe it yeah we have some
great stories today really well-rounded
I tried to you know diversify from like
all Kardashian stuff for sure you know
you have your area of expertise we want
to lean into that let's lean in
that's right about leaning in I I feel
like I'm a queen here this is a throne I
love it it's like the best this is like
the best
what like version of like a makeup
studio like I feel like I'm in someone's
like powder room no totally we should
actually start doing our makeup here
because the lighting in here is better
than perfect look how do I look you two
you look good I'm working it yeah you're
owning the throne I'm happy to be here
so welcome to the show a lot of toasters
are so excited that you're here and
they're big fans of yours but for those
of you who might not know what you do
please share with the class
well I have two podcast ones called the
J train podcast and another is called
the uuhh podcast you up I do with
betches you know that they're you know
like you guys you know big Instagram
people and the UI podcasts we get dating
advice so we talk about modern dating
problems and what's going on and I kind
of what I I'm like a spy who's turned on
my own so people are getting inside
information inside info right inside the
male brain and and I don't think you
know listen I'm a not an expert I would
never call myself that I'm a person with
a loud opinion which all of us have and
I'm also 10% away from the guy you've
dated or dumped you or you've dumped or
the guy you're texting with and you're
not sure what he means by what you know
let's do something and it's like I can
give an answer that I'm just a normal
dude that can give an answer to what
this guy is go you know kind of his
thought process okay very fair so what
does let's do something means it means
the guy wants to me it's there's a lot
of non-committal commitments going on
yeah so it's like a lot of guys are just
want a lot of guys want to be casual as
possible until the very end you'll be
getting you'll be getting
we still are we something and he'll be
like no no you know we're exclusive but
we're not dating but that's a big thing
now exclusive but not together yeah and
you're like what does that even mean
what's so true so you can't have sex
with anyone else right like only the
tough parts and none of the good parts
of like show up for me and support me
and be with me in public
yeah the emotional commitment not there
but listen we'll only have sex with each
other and if you have sex with anyone
else I'll be pissed right and it's like
but now you don't even get that I have
no date for a wedding so it's like what
so there's a lot of things going on but
you know in the margins in the you know
not being written down that people have
questions on and and listen modern
dating stuff it's said there's always
one girl in the group that's like it's
not whatever band and you're like okay
it's just different you know it's just
not the same as it used to be and none
of us can go to our parents and be like
oh like our parents can't give advice on
Instagram snapchat Twitter they don't
know what anything means you can't go
well mom dad like 30 pictures of moms in
a row on Instagram and that's how they
got together like we have nothing no
frame of reference
no frames and you talk to your parents
about this and they look at you like
you're crazy and and I'm just a product
of timing I'm older than you I when I
went to college there was no Facebook
then you got Facebook and then there was
dating websites and then it became the
swipe apps and then Twitter Instagram
snapchat Linkedin how does this all work
in and I've kind of you know a lot of it
you know there's just timing I've grown
up with it I was single through all of
that stuff so I can just speak to the
male thing of why he likes 10 of your
pictures in a row that is so funny
and very very pertinent to a lot of
people's situations so we thought
something fun to do so at the end of the
show people who are watching live on
YouTube please comment if you would like
any dating advice from Jared because I
think we have an expert on our hands and
honestly I was up at my old college this
weekend at Colgate they invited me which
is really every alumni stream is just to
be like semi important
to be asked to speak are you kidding me
because all of us kind of like we get
out of college and or like that place
never wants to speak to me again and
they're like please come up and talk to
youse and you're like sitting there with
a vodka soda like what do I know but
that's amazing right it was really
amazing I met some really great girls of
course like only females came with my
session but that was fine and it was
actually like a women's empowerment
weekend which I didn't realize they
brought up up a lot of female alums and
successful in different fields and I was
there representing like the Instagram
thirst monsters how to become one this
is a gram thirst monster yeah here it's
like when someone's thirsty extra
there's either a thirst monster and like
when they're beyond their thirst monster
general they're like are there these
people just like they're like I want in
on this pot of gold
yeah people you know who are like at a
party and they don't talk to anyone the
whole time yet like then they post a
picture like they were the life of the
power my god I you know or like take a
picture with the celebrity like go up to
them like hi like it's something like
I'm a big fan take a selfie and then be
like great night out gigi hadid yeah
yeah hang in with G they're almost like
they're like sneak attack Instagram yeah
yeah yeah you just look at their in
serum you're like wow they're crushing
it happen to see them in the wild it's a
dangerous thing in this day and age it's
like announcing who you are before being
who you are right and you see that a lot
on dating apps where it's like I'm an
introvert extrovert and it's like yeah
that's a person yeah you're both how did
that happen and it's like I'm the the
queen of all you know whatever it is and
it's like that's kind of how you know
where someone's at the party it's like
you're saying and then all of a sudden
me and JJ it's like no one spoke to you
you were in the corner exactly so
actually for the like the industry that
we're in and the jobs that we want to
have we're not as thirsty as we should
be but we're trying you know and every
once in a while like will up the level
of thirst cos in this world like being
thirsty is the equivalent of like
networking sure another thing I'm
terrible at there's like classy thirst
yes called networking yes
but you know sometimes sometimes you see
someone that's like so good at it
they're like wow you you've nailed this
whole game and then when you see someone
bad at it you're like oh wow you're
right you just don't know how to do this
like I'm someone who's horrible at
networking and I've also learned like
I'm also self-aware so I've given up and
you know what I think you can get by in
the world without ever networking like
every networking event I ever went to
mhm it's time I will never get back well
I agree I think the the key to life is
to constantly go am I crazy
you just have to have one moment am I
crazy in dating and in and just in job
stuff with you know networking you just
like when you go to a networking event
it's like you're like what am I doing
here and then if you talked to one
person you go yeah I don't know what
we're doing here and they go I know
right and then all of a sudden the whole
walls down right knocking for real right
that's always happening at this event
this weekend like I felt so like I felt
well identified with the students
because I'm like only five years out um
and then we were just talking about
networking in general and I was just
like well you guys are here at 8:30 on a
Saturday this like woman's alumni event
like you're ready doing something right
like when I was a student I would have
never been doing something like this and
they were all talking about you know
like the difficulties of coming out of
their shell like doing things like this
and networking and that made it all more
fun that is very true I kind of think of
that like I like I'm always like I'm
always I got a new diet thing I'm always
trying to like lose some weight and I'm
always there's one thing I'm like if I
could wake up and take a multivitamin
I'm already doing it yeah like I'm
already like a multivitamin you know
away from being a dirt pack you know
like I'm like one better I'm just one
thing better than I was before yeah and
it's like just like you said what you
know what the 90% of things are showing
up like that's a Woody Allen quote like
you came on a Saturday and you weren't
just laying in bed moaning because
you're hungover exactly you did it
you've won you weren't just lying in bed
moaning because you were hungover and
you didn't have liquid IV why does that
work do you know what I'm talking about
Electric hum over and you're just like
sitting there and then you go
and you're like that made me feel better
yes yeah because it's like for a few
seconds your energy like you're just
distracting yourself I think yeah maybe
that's it
but it's also the lack of electrolytes
which is why liquid an IV is so
pertinent to every hungover situation
when I was thinking about like college
and then I wanted to go back to the
dating piece because that's what made me
talk about Colgate the hangovers that
you thought that you had in college
nothing nothing no and that's what I
kept talking about like to these kids I
was like I would be hungover in my 8:30
class an oxymoron yeah cuz if you're
hungover you're not making it to need no
no hangover means you've given up on
everything in your life yes right whoops
so now I've turned to liquid IV which is
not your average electrolyte drink mix
using cellular transport technology a
specific ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium when mixed with 16 ounces of
water it helps your body absorb more of
the water and nutrients you drink
directly into your bloodstream it is the
best hangover cure
I found yet and it's tasty too Jackie
I'll say this I've had liquid IV delish
one two just like we said when you get
to the networking event at least you
showed up right
liquid IV is like one of those things
it's like you know you like forget to
shower when you're hungover you ever do
that you're like you're like oh my god I
feel horrible it's oh yeah you haven't
showered you have been gotten dressed
you haven't done the thing right you
haven't done any steps you just sat here
and sit among over that doesn't do
anything you even get up to get an Advil
you know so but liquid IV is like one of
those things like help yourself help
yourself I I had a friend he would go he
would I would she would always go I'm
hungover but I just take a long shower
and I'd be like I and to me I was like
you walk to the shower like how could
you and it's like yes do something
liquid IV is a positive a big step and
if you do one you can hold off on the
others for a while yeah anyways I love
liquid IV and I know that you will too
right now our listeners are getting 20%
off at liquid IV calm
when you use code toast at checkout
that's 20% off anything you order on
liquid i beez websites see i always call
that free money you want some free money
right here
liquid ID is the fastest-growing
hydration branding can find them
everywhere even Costco you can find them
at all of Costco's nationwide oh that's
great go to liquid IV calm and enter our
promo code toes to get your savings and
start getting better hydration that's
liquid IV calm promo code toast don't
wait get hydrated today boom boom so
back to college because I was with my
husband now which is just so crazy you
know me five years out of college and
then in the library with your husband
congratulations thank you is he gonna
Colgate as well he did not then he went
to USC which is a great segue to our
first story but you talking about you
know the subliminal messages of modern
dating like I really could have used
your expertise back in college
well what did how did you guys meet we
met a combo of a dating app and at work
so it wouldn't have happened if one of
those things didn't exist we had matched
on a dating app before I started working
at my job when I started working there
he knew that we had matched but I didn't
because I wasn't like keeping up with my
apps and then we connected at a
corporate kickball league listen he told
me that we had match and then I was like
oh he's single and straight like cool
see this is the beauty of the beauty and
the horror of dating app oh yes I at one
point when I was single in New York City
and I was on dating I was always doing
all the right things and putting myself
out there like cuz even if it didn't
work out like I'm just I'm gonna you
know sure just put myself out there and
I felt like I was getting famous from
dating apps like I felt like I was
seeing guys on the subway you were like
I've seen her oh oh my god you're the
one from hinge yeah exactly
yeah see the beauty of that of how you
guys met is he knew enough that you
thought he was a little bit good-looking
yes and like he had that little thing in
his mind where he's like we've already
matched right so I know she at least
doesn't think I'm that much of an animal
to not hit the like that's a beautiful
thing and a dangerous thing at the same
time because you know for a lot of women
out there that are out there dating it's
tight what's become hard is that men be
can be lazier now like for him that was
motivating
yes it motivated him he goes she thinks
I'm a little bit attractive I can go
talk to her and say hey we match on a
dating app we should go out yes
the other side of that is that men owned
a thought and a woman's brain that they
know well she thinks I'm hot so I don't
to do anything now so it can be you know
forever that's gravity for every up
there's a doubt so you know when people
are like one of them there's no rules to
dating but just know this is what's
going on guys own the thought that you
think I'm good-looking enough to like
okay maybe I don't have to do much or
maybe that's why I'm approaching exactly
Wow
how important do you think it is for
people the modern people who are dating
to be on dating apps I don't you know
what I have to you have to do what's
comfortable for you I think putting
yourself out there in any way is
important you got to play in traffic to
get hit that's the only way it's gonna
happen so yeah if you're someone that's
like you know I think dating apps are a
great way to put your toe in the water I
don't think it's the whole thing though
if you're sitting at home on a Saturday
night with your dating app and saying
well I'm out there you're not really out
there are you hanging with your friends
are you doing things that interests you
so you're around other people that are
interested in the same thing as you yeah
you know like when you go to your you go
to a work networking thing that's some
like-minded folks and those are people
that are into the same thing as you
that's playing in traffic so those are
you know like it's like going to you
know those are waters that are full of
fish you know you're like there's a lot
of fish in the sea but what sea are you
fishing it you know you're like in the
clubs like those are the fish yeah if
you're doing like and also like being
fun with your friends is so underrated
as a dating thing because your friends
are guys want to be around fun women and
if you're sitting out there if you're
out with your friends doing a day drink
and I'm not saying day drinking is like
go get wasted I'm saying just be around
fun things complain events when I I
remember my buddies and I we were on a
group trip out in Chicago and there was
like a group of women with all like pink
Wayfarer sunglasses and we were like we
have to talk to those women they all
wore the same thing that's how easy it
to be fun you don't have to be out there
you're chugging tequila right okay so
the matching outfits like those bachelor
parties that's a good thing I think
that's a good thing to show that you do
stuff right and that like you're you're
having the time in you're looking for
good yeah
and it's and then you know I think now
with when I talked about the girl who's
like dating in 2019 is awful like this
you know the doomsday dater and we've
all met this girl the Doomsday dinner
and and the never no one's ever had
issues dating and any other time women
were trading for cows at some point like
you know things were tough back then too
so I but with that person there's it's
like yeah of course you're not doing
well you're you're angry about the whole
thing go get off the date I think it's
as important to get off the dating apps
as it is to be on them yeah take a break
try something new I was on a break when
Zach and I matched originally mm-hmm
because I was just like having a great
summer taking so many photos and I just
didn't have enough space on my phone to
have a dating app that's a great reason
but you know what you know it's like
it's like when you you have ideas in the
shower it's because you're showering
that's a lot like dating no you don't
have your coat you're not distracted
you're not down on your phone in the
doubt you know you know the darkness of
like I'm single I'm on this app again
everyone everyone's asking about my
weekend I didn't do anything this
weekend how are you what do you do the
same conversation 7,000 times and then
finally you're like well screw it I'm
gonna go out with my friends and then
somebody then you meet a group of
friends and and that's you know it just
changes things up you got to just keep
like cleansing and stuff and keep going
and also like this is hard
remember like 9 out of 10 people you
meet aren't the one the 10th one ends in
divorce 50% of the time happy
Valentine's Day [ __ ] it's like it's
it's not easy so admit to that right you
know don't never been easy and it's not
supposed to be easy because this is like
a bit though you know the risk is worth
the reward or whatever you know yeah you
and your boyfriend don't have every days
of great every day isn't a great day are
you your husband I'm sorry
yeah no every day isn't a great day and
I think that's like the Instagram thing
right where it's like oh you see
everyone else with their boyfriend and
then their fiance and then their wedding
and you're like I want those things
right and it looks so easy they've just
got together sure gotta get you they got
married and this is another thing from
the male point of view
like an ally I don't know if a lot of
women are gonna want to hear this we are
very aware of when you're just inserting
a boyfriend into an Instagram shot we're
very aware of the girls that are like we
don't care who the guy is I just want a
body to have in this picture I think
that's a new thing it's a new thing it's
very tough and like guys women think men
have no emotional intelligence
whatsoever so you think we're just like
how do I do this I don't know I got her
going for drinks who wants drink we know
what's going on we are we are like we
are blessed Faline I Eve like blissfully
naive we we will go we will act like we
have zero emotional intelligence to just
get out of [ __ ] yeah so that's the same
thing with like you know so a lot of
women they'll go well he won't realize
that I'm I'm just looking for a guy to
be in my I just want a boyfriend and
it's like we know when girls just want a
boyfriend meaning they'll take anything
but who shows up to the ice-cream shop
and says give me ice cream no you got to
choose I want vanilla bean I want you
know chocolate raspberry you're like we
want to be chosen we want to win you
this is a video game culture what guy
doesn't like to win the video game
that's kind of how dating has to be and
you have to and you got to play a better
game I think a lot of people you know
when they complain about the dating
world it's raining out bring an umbrella
time to change it up bring an umbrella
okay that's some really great advice
we're gonna get back to all that because
without further ado we must hit you with
the fast side stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast let's do it
okay first story a little bit of poetic
justice dr. Jay brags his daughter got
into USC quote on her yet on her own
years after a 7 million dollar donation
okay so dr. Dre was dancing on the
graves yeah Lori Loughlin felicity
and when he was abruptly called out yeah
and you know what so many people are
like still defending not defend not that
there's much to defend they're saying he
did it legally but that's not what the
caption said the caption said on her own
he should have said my daughter got in
the old-fashioned way
my daughter got in the legal way but on
her own seventy million dollars is not
on anyone's own and I'm sure she's a
bright girl but I'm her own does not
apply here it's my favorite story I love
the Internet is undefeated mm-hmm we
know that the Internet just never loses
the internet never forget never forget
never lose you just can't I just don't
think you can [ __ ] the Internet
and that's what he's doing he's doing a
version he's the parent that we all kind
of got annoyed with growing up were
they're like my child didn't need a
tutor for their SATs they just needed a
whole music department exactly what's so
crazy so my husband went to USC marching
talking about it a bit this weekend
because some of the other alums had
connections to USC and for those who
don't know USC I was there in the fall
okay who are just school like to the
point where it feels palatial it feels
like I'm on that set you know it's
palatial beautiful and people were
making fun of USC like oh you're gonna
get 500 grand again the Muse it's a good
school it's a nice school you know so
your husband went there he went there
and he was actually talking about with
one of the alums this new program that
dr. Dre had started it's a music
entertainment like an entrepreneurship
program like a major in a new building
and so he just been talking about in
then dr. Dre posted this Instagram and
Zach was showing me and then he was like
that's so funny because he I was just
talking about the young school that's
that's dr. Dre it was like so he didn't
get it in her own eyes like I hope
someone calls these people out funny me
cuz I got busy and we're going to dinner
but like I hope the internet figures
this out someone at home and their
basements gonna figure this one out for
us I it is so like of the times like
this whole story is of the times where
it's like a it just it's so juicy and
delicious then it's like perfectly made
for the internet it is funny to just
have someone stand under a building
with their own name on it going I gotta
here on my own I can't believe I pick
myself up by the bootstraps I made it
oh my god there's life and you know what
I think right now we're the Internet and
the time what we live in we're living in
a who's had it worse off everyone's got
to have it worse than that the only
reason you can have an opinion is if you
came from something below someone else
who you don't want work wouldn't and
when you talk about people when you rate
the privileges now you can't just have
someone at the top of the the privilege
chart there's gonna be number two number
three number four number five and then
all the way down the list and you know
dr. Dre who's a guy who's probably you
know he came from you know nowhere to be
dr. Dre he in his mind you know listen
we've had our family instead of talked
and he doesn't even probably see these
like what she did it all on her own and
you're like yeah you your daughter lived
a different childhood than I did even
see the hypocrisy and why should he
he's dr. Dre let him live but I he's
just a proud parent and it you would
like you said if he had worded
differently he would have been so there
he should have just said the legal way
because it is legal to donate a building
and curry favor for admissions for the
rest of time yes absolutely and it's
also legal to go congratulations to my
daughter you can just you can just say
something nice about someone without
demeaning other people in the process
and it's like right and that's it's like
the schadenfreude yeah everyone loves
these days I would think that maybe dr.
Dre would be above it and especially
considering you know he's like it's not
on her own so maybe he's realizing
people might call him out and it is you
know what the other thing is like you
know life is hard and and when we go
call out other people like listen and
that's not to say there's privilege in
everything there's there's you know
there's all privileges exists all around
us in different levels in different ways
and everyone admits to that but you know
when you look at someone and go your
life was easy like that was that
person's life you don't know what they
dealt with like I'm sure his daughter is
sitting there going I studied hard I got
into USC like it's not her fault that
her dad was like you know screw you Bob
Becky
like right it's like you know everyone
has their own things and their own
mountains to get over and like getting
up in the morning isn't easy and it's
not everyone has their own things in
their own mind so it is interesting that
like you know we live in this time it's
like bring your resume of why you're sad
to be able to like live and it's like no
just go to college right and it's just
hilarious i I do enjoy though like that
the internet like they're like wait a
minute here's a 70 million dollar
building you put up right on her own
it's on her own you did it you did it
little Dre okay next door hey picked for
you because I'm assuming you're a sports
fan I like me some sports Patriots Rob
Gronkowski announced his retirement at
29 it's time to move forward Wow over a
month after winning the Super Bowl New
England Patriots tight end Rob
Gronkowski announced on Sunday he's
retiring from the NFL quote it all
started 20 years ago on stage at the NFL
Draft when my dream came true and now
here I am about to turn 30 in a few
months with a decision I feel is the
biggest of my life so far I will be
retiring from the game of football today
he wrote on Instagram I'm so grateful
for the opportunity that mr. Kraft and
coach Belichick gave to me when drafting
my silliness in 2010 my life experiences
over the last nine years have been both
have been amazing both on and off the
field the people I have met the
relationships I've built the
championships I have been a part of I
just want to thank the whole New England
Patriots organization for every
opportunity and there's more but that is
the gist it's a sad day for me I'm a
Patriots fan of them from outside of
Boston I grew up a Patriots fan I love
Gronk more than I love my own parents I
am such a Gronk fan he is just so much
fun like he's a the the the reason we're
talking about him on the morning toast
is he's a personality he is larger than
life he you want you see him and you
want to give my hug you know so for me
as a Patriots fan I'm sad to lose them
you know for the team that I'd cheer for
I'm even more sad to lose them as a
personality I don't know what the net
they say my going to wrestling or
whatever he's gonna end up doing I don't
know what that is but
I hope it's like as fun as I hope it
doesn't get like sad I hope it's gonna
get sad what I had heard and I don't
remember what made us think this is like
he's gonna go like a John Cena route in
terms of like movies and animation and
just like becoming this fun character I
mean you know now I'm happy he gets to
spend more time concentrating on his
stand-up that he was doing before I I
just love him like I you know some
people they just have that it thing you
know you know we were talking before
some people are good at networking and
they don't make you feel like you're
being networked yes Gronk has this
incredible incredible ability to not
make you to make you feel like a child
watching him do stuff yeah and not a lot
of people have that know so that's why I
think like whatever he does next it's
gonna be good and positive I think he's
gonna have like a lot of success because
people just want to see what he's doing
in support yeah and you know you know
someone is likable when they make a
thousand sixty-nine references and we
all just go Oh grog blow jobs up my god
come on like if he wasn't likable we
would go okay man it's enough with the
[ __ ] jokes you know but we love Gronk
so he can do no wrong some people have
that ability you know there was a lot of
stuff that came out where in the NFL
like you know certain players were
getting judged harshly on certain
subjects and then they go look at Gronk
and it's like no no no no no we all
don't get likability and and and it's
it's the hardest thing in the world to
describe and to know in Gronk just has
it it you look at him laughing and you
start laughing and it's like and this is
you know life isn't fair you know that
Jimmy the doctor Jays daughter gets to
go to whatever college she wants to
mm-hmm life isn't fair Gronk gets to
make as many [ __ ] jokes as he wants
and we just laugh and giggle and I love
that I love because I used to like I
used to work in a summer camp and there
was this kid who was like he would he
would go out you remember the crazy
crakes remember those chairs they're
great they were great it was
right they'd like someone that that's
like the George Foreman grill of chairs
like someone was just like yeah just put
them together and you sitting there like
you're like wait a minute I'm in my own
rocking chair this is crazy that cost
them 10 cents to make and we bought it
for 50 bucks and you had to have seven
of them with a bag on the back so I
remember there was this kid that I was a
counselor for and he was like what you
know he was like going around and like
he was just like one of those kids that
like was a pain in the ass but like you
couldn't help but laugh at the stuff he
did he was like the Gronk of the bunk
yeah and I remember one time he was
going around the people´s crazy creeks
and clipping I'm clipping that's the
most annoying thing you could do and I
remember one time he was about he's
literally like going up to unclip and I
look over I'm like and he just looks at
me goes yeah fine do it and then he did
it I was like you know not everyone can
give you the yeah where were you a
counselor in Maine I worked in the
summer camp with my cedar oh yeah oh
[ __ ] holy oh my I don't worry yeah yeah
great gal great gals I know a lot of
people are a lot of fun people a lot of
vegans a lot of vegans I know a lot of
vegans and not the annoying guy totally
okay speaking of likability Joe just
talked about two people who worked hard
to get where they are cedar and Vega did
nothing and now we have camp toast oh
really what's that like a camp weekend
for the toasters in the Poconos Oh
one coming up Memorial Day weekend and
it's just like everything you you think
that's fun uh-huh here's without some
advices the camp toasters don't be that
person that shows up the camp toaster
goes at my camp we did it this way let
it happen right but also so many of the
toasters didn't go to camp Oh what the
full experience and so there isn't like
they're not comparing like that and
they're just enjoying they just like
camp
that's great those are the boats and to
it alcohol oh it's just like I mean how
many of us now looking back want a
little vodka with our bug juice right
all of us yeah all of us a little rosy
in the now gee that's right Joe Joe see
why jokes she and Kim Kardashian are
best friends
amid collaboration with Northwest so
Jojo announced see I don't know a lot
about JoJo's CY but I just told you who
she is before the show yeah you do
recognize her I recognize her from the
the Bieber thing and she's also like a
Nickelodeon influencer I think they like
sponsor her and her core she was at the
Kids Choice Awards she dresses
Nickelodeon ish yeah it feels like her
her attire is and this is an old
reference now I guess she looks like an
like she dresses like an episode of
Clarissa explains it all right she looks
like her bedroom on a person right and
her bedroom looks like that and her
whole house looks like that her whole
life is like Jojo see walk I'd propose
the car that doesn't either made fun
gotcha
this all makes sense she is a YouTube
influencer and she announced that she is
doing a makeup video with Northwest who
we know from Kim is huge into makeup and
we know from Ken's Instagram stories has
a huge personality okay
and apparently Kim and Jojo have been
texting about it and came really excited
and this will be our first foray into
like North on the internet so North West
how old is she she is she must be like
six or seven now into makeup like we
like this she's starting her own you
know Kylie Jenner billionaire Empire is
that I don't know she's starting makeup
that she is Leslie like she uses all of
her mom's makeup okay Jim doesn't make
up tutorials she'll show her like
palettes and she'll be like obviously
North got into this one controller out
maybe watch Kardashians apparently North
is like an animal like she goes to a
restaurant she just like like eats
everything plays with everything she
goes into she did kidding me even did
like a Instagram video once when North
was like going through all of her makeup
and she is loves to wear me okay this is
so we're getting a tutorial from the two
of them and I'm really excited this is
exciting this is exciting news this is I
just like the thought like talking about
go back to the dr. Dre story it's like
North did it all on her own right she
started her makeup Empire we're gonna
look back 30 years from now but a
self-made billionaire North West
Kylie Jenner is self-made do you yes how
sup cuz everything like how many rich
and famous children turn out to be worse
than anyone worse off than anyone
blowing money they like it's honest it
might even you could argue I'm not gonna
be the one to argue at that sometimes
it's harder to make something from
yourself when you've started with so
much because what is your incentive says
she's put all of her own money into her
business and the way that she built her
missus you could say if she didn't have
money she wouldn't have been able to do
that but she did start small like her
mom did say like if this doesn't work
out you're gonna have a garage full of
lip kits like I think that she built it
in a conservative way that really a lot
of people could have started that way
even with just a loan you know yeah I I
don't think I think we get into
semantics about this because it's like
the self-made thing I actually think
that this is this is my conspiracy at
the area is that kris kardashian put in
the headline self-made because she just
wants people arguing about it so it
keeps it in the news so it's like just
even this debate right now is us talking
about it they never included and it's a
free commercial for anyone who doesn't
yeah it's like anyone who doesn't know
she has a cosmetics line now knows again
so i I do think the self-made thing like
again like what we were talking about
before is like everyone has a tough life
to them because through their own eyes
and the minute like life isn't fair you
know you make what you make a bit Kylie
okay they could have been robbed could a
bit well that's it you know that's a rob
some would say he has no problems in the
world you don't I mean like some would
say it's like I don't even know what his
issues are but I'm saying he's not in
the news anymore he's not on the show
anymore you know so yeah you know some
would say well he still has it he even
though he has his own thing going on
yeah so it's it's i I don't like the
self-made thing like I don't care you
know I I care just cuz like people just
love to tear them down sure you can
become the war
world's youngest billionaire and still
it's not good enough because she started
out okay but no one's it's never gonna
be good enough people like it they were
always gonna you know we live in the the
time if you're rich you're evil you know
so it's like it kind of feels like one
of those things where it's like the
self-made thing like yeah it's gonna
piss people off yeah you know I mean you
see it with other industries or it's
like if you get you know introductions
are a huge deal so if she was introduced
to someone you know via knowing someone
else like okay there you go you're in
it's true okay
next story it's a compilation of stories
okay it's Diana Ross and Barbra
Streisand we're defending Michael
Jackson this weekend
first up parents to blame Barbra
Streisand's shocking take on Michael
Jackson allegations Barbra Streisand
blamed the parents of Michael Jackson's
alleged abuse victims in an interview
with a British newspaper on Friday
speaking to The Times of London strides
and addressed the sexual abuse claims
brought by Wade Robson and James safe
truck in the new HBO documentary leading
netherland strides an told the newspaper
that she doesn't doubt Jackson to keep
abuse Robson and safe truck when they
were children but she placed blame for
it on their parents not the King of Pop
quote I blame my guests the parents who
would allow their children to sleep with
him she told the newspaper the outlet
described Streisand's attitude to
Jackson who once asked her to sing a
duet with him as quote surprisingly
sympathetic she added that both the
children who spoke about their abuse at
the hands of Jackson in the documentary
quote both married and they both have
children so it didn't kill them quote
his sexual needs were his sexual needs
coming from whatever childhood he has or
whatever DNA he has quote you can say
molested but those children as you heard
say they were thrilled to be there she
told the newspaper
it's a tough quote it's a tough quote
now and now she is clarified Yoko those
comments after the backlash she said to
be crystal clear there is no situation
or circumstance where it was okay for
the innocence of children to be taken
advantage by anyone the stories these
two young men shared were painful to
hear and I feel nothing but sympathy for
them the single most important role of
being a parent is to protect their
children it's clear that the parents of
the two young men were also victimized
and seduced by Fame and fantasy honestly
it sounds like you were seduced by Fame
and fantasy that you just keep defending
him because in the same way they brought
their kid
staying out with Michael Jackson because
they were so honored she's defending
Michael Jackson so honored that she sang
a duet with him
it's a tough and this is one of those
stories that you're like Barbara take a
seat
yeah don't let's let's sit on the bench
you'll come back for an easier story and
it come back from the dr.dre yeah come
back for the ones that we know what the
opinion is like this is one of those
that's like I'm leavin myself like back
away you know like you tiptoe out of the
room yeah people are like let's talk
about Michael Jackson I'm like I need a
coffee
you need a coffee need water anybody and
then I walk back in and we're talking
about sea walk with it you know like
this is so you know you see him the I
don't I don't know obviously I I don't I
don't really agree with what she said I
don't know it's one of those it's like
you know there are certain stories right
now because you have to have an opinion
on everything if you're out there with
opinions now you have to have an opinion
on everything so like Barbra Streisand
if you go to her Twitter account like
she's got a like a lot of political [ __ ]
she's got a lot of like she's got it
she's on everything I don't go to her
Twitter I went after reading this story
because I was like what is she about
what is she about if this was the one
thing she came out about like was like I
gotta put my you know flag in the sand
I'd be like yeah well she really
believed but then if you go through her
couch she's got opinions on everything
everything things that are above her pay
grade right you know that you just you
don't know anything about but this is
what happens it's like you know you
forget there's certain stories I'm gonna
take a seat on I don't know anything
it's okay to say I don't know it's okay
to go really difficult situation I don't
know you know it's like those what we
can do we could all do that in our own
lives a little bit more like you know we
could all do one of those gonna back off
I'll get the coffee that's what we
should start calling it these are this
is it I'll get the coffee story because
obviously what the Michael Jackson thing
with the documentary that's coming out
it's what you find and just from talking
to people it's so tough for
people to separate their own feelings
with the music and their own childhood
experiences just like she's saying I had
to do wet is so difficult for people to
separate one thing from the other and
also while not knowing anything right we
weren't there we were going by a damning
documentary I'm not defending I'm just
saying like it's okay to go seems
horrible I don't know anybody need
coffee
that's me my whole life I just want to
be the guy on difficult stories as goes
hey maybe anything like I just want to
be the mom who's like I know let me
clean up you know like you let me get
the kids need some drinks right yes
Diana Ross could have you know taking
that can we get a coffee here because
she tweeted okay this is what's on my
heart this morning I believe in trust
that Michael Jackson was and is a
magnificent incredible force to me and
to many others she then added stop in
the name of love see that she's
promoting her own you could buy it on
iTunes today again you know you don't
know how this is why I love podcasts
because you can hear in people's voices
you can hear the the hem and haw like
that you know and Twitter you can't hear
that
no no Diana Ross we're just like stop in
the name of Allah did you just promote
your album
did you just promote your album at the
end of your Michael Jackson support like
it's like and is this thought coming at
the end of a series of thoughts where
you're conflicted about how to feel
about him but you know he was
magnificent in certain ways so stop in
the name of love this is like just this
just stop talking I try to have empathy
in every situation I try you know an
empathy for the empathizer
huh so I could see where she's like I
got this you know we had a life together
and some some interviewers like you got
to tweet about this and you're like
Diana then picks up her phones like
what's Twitter you know like in like all
of a sudden she's typing like your
parents do where they hold it like this
you know like and then you're like okay
now we're supposed to take this as
seriously as like a journalist that
might do this or have the
opinion or like I don't know it's all
the the world lives in gray and Twitter
does not so the world nothing on Twitter
gets a retweet that's like you know what
gets retweets love and hate love and
hate on and never and and no one's ever
that hundred percent on either side
right so that you know I feel again
everyone need coffee if you wanted a
drink or anything I can get you guys I
got I got snacks you know that's what I
do on those stories that's a great point
okay our fifth story's a little more
lighthearted considering everyone
survived but a cruise ship from Norway
reaches a port with remaining passengers
after Mayday and air rescues a cruise
ship ship stranded off Norway's western
coast has reached port with its
remaining passengers the Viking sky ship
airlifted more than half of its nine
hundred passengers to safety before
authorities opted Sunday to allow the
ship to limp into the nearby port of
Mull day with aid of a tow boat all
passengers and crew are safe and
passengers will be flying home
starting tonight the cruise line said in
a statement throughout all of this our
first priority was for the safety and
well-being of our passengers in our crew
we would like to thank the Norwegian
reddening Central and the Norwegian
emergency services for their support and
skill displayed in managing the
situation in very challenging weather
conditions Viking Sky issued a mayday
Saturday after engine troubles in a
harrowing encounter with rough waters
and high winds off Norway's western
coast okay so you saw the video I saw
the video things are flying around the
the port you know the the deck the Lido
deck
is in turmoil have you ever been on a
cruise no and I mean not that I was
planning on it yeah now death not this
is end I've been on a bunch of cruise
like family vacations and stuff I they
have this whole lifeboat drills and it's
like why do they have the lifeboat
drills if they're not you they're
airlifting right I guess it was easier
to airlift I don't know how far out they
were and also when you're looking in
that video it's like how would you even
get a lifeboat like it's mayhem you
can't even walk the furniture it looked
obviously it looked alive it looks like
it look like you're right piano
Lumiere's singing
[Laughter]
floating around whoo you see a teacup
yeah you're right that was surprising
too because it's like what aren't these
boats built with the idea that this
could happen right just a wait it's
gonna just the cushions are flying out
so a ridiculous story everything I was
on a cruise once I was like 15 years old
and I'm like with my parents and my
brother and I have a younger brother
we're sharing a room and I had got I
went out drinking oh yeah you know I was
15 I'm sneaking shots or whatever so I I
remember I was drunk and then the boat
you know hit a wave and I was in bed
like hungover I couldn't use the
electrolytes the IV drink but I remember
the boat did like one of the you you
feel it like back and forth and then I
felt that one of them just went back and
just didn't stop and I rolled out of my
bed and into my brother's bed like
that's how like much it kept going and
like I'm completely naked so now I'm
just in bed with my brother like how did
I end up here and he's like what are you
doing I was like it's the boat we didn't
mean to do this and then they came on
the last because like listen I don't
know the numbers but they were like
usually it's a grade five that was a 15
we can handle up to a 50 like these
boats are built for this built for this
but when it gets a little when you get
something out of the ordinary you you
know they they had drinks falling off
the bar shelves they're like we're out
of cups because everything's smash
that's crazy and my brother and I now
know each other in a really intimate way
I mean wow would you score but would you
go on another cruise now they're
discounted you get a good deal do you
feel like like the Mayday calls and like
technology is definitely more advanced
and it was saying that during the
Titanic I would hope so so so it the
fact that everyone survived that it was
not catastrophic is wonderful it's
absolutely I just it's amazing to me
because when you first get on a cruise
they're like take the you know they're
like you know we're gonna do the drill
they have like a whole drill yeah they
do a drill where you like you line up
for your life phone it's it's a little
you it's in your head but it's like now
I'm like why they do the mustard on that
drill like why weren't those boats used
yeah there must be a reason I don't know
I'm Diana Ross I don't know some of then
I think were you some people were
airlifted and then the rest were tugged
to port okay yeah I you know the cruise
I have no idea what I'm talking about
ai ai ai ai I'll say with this with the
with the boats the worst part about a
cruise everyone's eating the same thing
so everyone's just starts to smell the
same yeah it's just like one big [ __ ]
factory I don't know it's it's cruises
they're fun but you know the story like
this you like yeah I'm not sprinting to
a cruise the worse that this story is
like a happy ending normally cruise
stories are like ever on the boat [ __ ]
their pants and you're like oh my god
yeah and the bathrooms don't work the
hours I was a video a few years ago of a
cruise ship that was like sinking but it
was so close to shore that it wasn't so
scary because even if you jumped off
like you that was Italy yeah I think
people like I think that was like a
serious thing yeah I don't know I don't
remember the story at all but I I do the
videos you're like this looks like it's
out of a movie yeah so I guess it has to
do with the disk proximity to shore
because if you're in the middle of the
Atlantic yay I ain't swimming home no
you're not okay well those are the fast
I stories thank you so much for helping
us of course in the meantime we have a
few more minutes left so if any of you
guys want to comment on the YouTube
stream with questions for Jared inglese
expertise and also you know if you are
dating I would recommend sent bird truly
except for this weekend cuz I didn't
check luggage okay and it's small a
Tweetup of rooms and you it's a
subscription but if you find a fragrance
that you like you can keep buying in
it's just like so perfect for your purse
perfect for a date I have I know
simpered they sponsor my show and I'll
say this what a great idea this is one
of those things it is hacked you know
they
the perfume cologne industry because you
used to spend like $100 on one cologne
or one perfume and then you're just
stuck with it uh-huh you don't get any
other that's your smell forever years to
finish about yeah so it's like semper
you can travel with it you can't oh I
didn't that's anything oh my if you're
going say I mean you could check it but
you can't have it in your carry-on
because it's too many too much liquid
you probably people have probably lost
thousands of dollars just from having
the TSA a guy go mm sorry now the TSA
guy smells great yes a guy it's like you
should try centers yeah and I think the
best part about sunburn is that you can
collect a bunch of them so you can have
different smells for different occasions
you can be like oh this is my Saturday
smell is my work smell like just to get
and you're never gonna use I mean they
say it's a month versus really use a
cologne guy so he could go through a
sunburn a month personally I like to
keep it a little bit lighter but sunburn
is a luxury fragrance subscription
service for perfumes and colognes a way
for you to discover new perfumes and
colognes without buying an entire bottle
that's the biggest thing that you can
like dabble yes anything you can
experiment with new sense without having
to like take a risk just based on an
advertisement for a perfume you know I
think perfume marketing is like
silliness yeah what Johnny Depp's and a
thousand scarves and outs you're
supposed to think good that's your fault
yeah come on with an exclusive offer for
just our listeners you can get 50% off
your first month today that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance go to scent bird dot-com slash
toast and use our code toast for 50% off
your first month
again that's scen t-bird comm slash
toast for you to try your first perfume
or cologne for just seven dollars and
fifty cents as I was gonna say I think
it's like seven seven dollars and fifty
cents is like crazy right like I'm
wearing Bulgari today for seven dollars
and fifty cents that's right Bulgari
people come on okay we have some really
great people writing in yes we do okay
good okay from Spencer lien how can I go
about asking my man about keeping our
relationship a secret from everyone for
just like six months just not into the
expectations in social drama about
don't want it to come off route so it's
kind of the opposite of what we were
talking about but this is very
interesting from the female perspective
you don't hear there's got to be a
reason what did they give a reason now
um they're not into the expectations and
like the social media time because I
think that's also a big thing is once
you post something with someone and
announce that you're dating you also
have to announce that you're not dating
and yeah I hate that with celebrities
where they put their slip their
relationship everywhere and then they
want us to just move on from it without
any explanation this is a huge issue
especially social media and like here's
the thing with relationships and I'm not
sure how old this woman is but like when
you post something you say you have a
boyfriend you save your girlfriend the
train leaves the station you now you've
left casual town and then it's like when
it ends when are you guys going to be
moving in and when are you getting
engaged and wait you have to deal with
all those questions it's it's stock
presentation yeah never lets it breathe
and I you know it's like buttoning up a
shirt and missing one of the buttons
you gotta unbutton all the way down the
shirt right so I think you I think any
guy to tell this person the truth guys
will like this yeah the guy she's with
is gonna want to be as casual as
possible for as long as possible so if
you sit and so if you say them it's okay
to say I'm just not ready for that yet I
like you I'm enjoying it I'm having fun
I'm just not ready for an Instagram post
I'm just not ready for Instagram stories
it's okay devil's advocate if a guy said
that to you you would think you would
just like take it as he doesn't wanna
you have to take it better that's my my
thing like and and also you have to like
not it's not one thing like I have a
girlfriend we it took us time to put
stuff on Instagram stories there's no
pictures of my my Instagram feed of us
together at whatever event and whatever
and she understands that because the
rest of the relationship is okay and
it's not one thing you have to create
kind of a resume of things to go oh this
isn't working so if you look at your
boyfriend or you look at your girlfriend
and say hey I'm having a great time with
you it's just not the time for us to do
that that's coming when we're ready but
now is not the time I think that's okay
and
that person can't take you for that then
they want the wrong things just like the
girl who wants the boyfriend in the
picture it's like maybe they're after
the wrong things that aren't a
relationship with you what are your tips
on getting back into the dating world
after a four-year relationship take it
slow
four year relationship you need reps you
need reps repetitions for those of us
not crushing it in the gym working on
our fitness the you need reps talking to
people because here's the thing I have a
lot of friends that are given
relationships I call it girlfriend
confidence where they're in a
relationship when a girl's been hooking
up with them for four years so they're
like every girl wants me it's like
nobody wants you you're the same you
were four years ago and you're four
years older so come on buddy you know
there's so I'm saying to her people do
want you but you have to get used to
talking to new people talking to
strangers that are safe and responsible
but so I would say to her go out with
your single friends let them show you
how they're working this world and kind
of be your Sherpa into the dating also
four years is like a lots changed in
four years totally I would actually say
don't go jump on apps right away like go
out with your single friends and if you
go I have no friends they're single
go all your friends have boyfriends and
they're single friends yeah get used to
talking to people in a way so you can
you know start figuring out the you know
the men you want you want to get your
your your muscles back and when you're
in a relationship you lose the muscle of
talking to new people yeah you know you
lose that muscle as much as you think oh
I'm so personable I'm what no no no no I
talk to people after shows every night
and I'll go hey nice to meet you and you
can tell that they they haven't met a
lot of variables they go to work they
talk to the person at work they go home
they talk to their wife or a husband or
whatever it is and then they come to the
show and I go hey nice to meet them they
go Friday you know it just it's one of
those things that like you know cuz we
go out and meet people everyday for this
job yeah we're used to like
if I don't do the show for a while I
come back and I'm rusty as hell rusty
you're rusty go out with friends go out
with like your single friends first your
aunt relationship friends second the
friends with boyfriends that it have fun
friends but just get you let them be
your Sherpa into the world great this is
a great question from Katy Pastore how
long is too long to chat on the dating
app before meeting in person this is a
great question question because it's not
there's no real answer okay there's two
[ __ ]
that you have to there's too short to
talk on a dating app and there's too
long the in-between is is it's on a
spectrum okay so too short is hey let's
do drinks hold on okay hold on wait you
saw a picture you like so now I have to
go there's a lot of people out there
that with pictures that I like and then
some people go well I don't want to
waste my you're wasting my time that I
might have to go out with you right like
maybe we could figure this out right now
if it's worth exploring absolutely so I
think that too long is anything longer
than a day so if you spent it's okay to
you how many of us have texted with
someone over the course of a day and had
a full conversation over a day at work
you what has to happen is it and I hate
to put a rule of a day but I'm saying
have enough of a conversation where
where it's fun and flirty and then it
has to end end in what's your plan next
week if it doesn't end in what's your
plan or making a plan it's over don't
you can't go say good night to someone
on a dating app and then wake up
tomorrow to say good morning if you're
doing that you're not that person is and
what people do over the dating apps and
what guys do a lot is they'll text with
you for as long as possible to build
trust so that they don't have to take
you out and they can just meet up a lot
of people out there and that's okay
that's something you want just it just
admit to it yeah but if you are looking
to date and to meet someone and have a
relationship it it has to start with hey
what's your plan next Tuesday want to do
eight o'clock drinks at this place
someone has to make
guy or girl I don't really care right
but if if you're avoiding that
conversation you're avoiding getting
turned down yeah for me the way I always
felt it's like obviously you're dating
criminals like your resume you know
certain things about this person but I
also want to you to tell me like I don't
want to know everything about you and
then I mean I'm like how's being an
accountant like tell me about your
accounting job blah blah so I don't want
to have a conversation where I know all
these things about you I want I would
even like forget where this person works
is like you don't have to study
everything you see the gist okay this is
doable and look and then you learn
things about each absolutely it's it's
really to get a taste of somebody and
say hey how are you where you from what
do you do
nice to meet you oh what'd you do this
weekend cool and to see if there's a
vibe it's like Hayden here's the thing
the beautiful like how many siblings do
you have
in the beauty of a dating app is you can
say goodbye and move on yeah you don't
have it's less than meeting in a bar
yeah the commitment level so hey nice to
meet you this conversation isn't really
going where next what do you think is
the best dating app if you if you would
recommend someone to only be on one
that's looking for a relationship i mean
i i'm i'm i work with hinge so i'll be
open about that but I do think hinge is
a great app for people if you're looking
for relationship I yeah is that's how
you guys met so I think with hinge the
prompts are a great thing the act of
liking versus swiping is is I think
that's physically a better thing yeah
like just doing this all day long that's
not like you know like that's nothing
yeah going boom is just a different
thing like I think like just mentally
physically like I think that all works
into it I I do think but I am paid by
them so I'll be open about that but I do
believe that that's a but I you know
Bumble I don't think you know it calls
itself a feminist app it's the best one
for men I'll be totally honest with you
I'm telling you good honest truth the
problem with dating apps on like tinder
was like guys the guys are like dogs
will eat until we die
so with dating we'll do the same thing
guys are also like depression-era
children we don't throw away leftovers
so we will always keep someone around
yeah for the if and when in case we get
hungry Gronk [ __ ] okay so so the
ideas tender the problem for men was
that you would get all these matches and
you go I got to talk to all the matches
right but you didn't know who liked you
the most of the matches who was the
closest to hooking up right what bumble
did for men is you get the matches and
then the the people that wanted to hook
up or hook up or be with you the most or
thought the most of you come and talk to
you so it changed the numbers and made
it easier for men does that make sense
though because tender you talked to him
on you didn't know because we all swipe
someone right or like someone's picture
for different reasons yeah even we don't
want to admit this but the truth of the
matter is you look at someone you go
that's a date person that's a hookup
person that's a wife that's a wife
that's a that's a husband that's guys
because we're all checking boxes right
so when you do that and you're swiping
tinder you're like I don't know which of
these is gonna come through but I got to
play them all yeah hey are bumble now
they're coming to you they're going I
think you're cute and please me yes that
makes it a lot easier for men what are
your thoughts on ghosting ghosting sucks
but I think it's like I think we're in a
tough spot with ghosting because we're
all doing it first of all understand
that guys are just whistles yeah they
don't but so our girls have like girls
are doing it to everyone's goes I think
that ghosting is sometimes like a
necessary evil like it's because some
relationships or a few dates don't
require a conversation well this is why
ghosting exists and then the act of the
ghost tells you everything well the
problem is there's no definitive
definite there's no definition for those
things I thought it was disappearing
after having had sex oh I don't know if
it's a sex thing well so this is the
thing we have a different complicate
yeah once that complicates it if you
were on one date with someone and then
they go hey we should do that again you
don't answer to me that's like a not
really a ghost thing to me to me that's
like okay
fine there's a more mature way to handle
this there's a more wavy and also what
what happened is there was a lot of
people getting offended with how you
would end things right so a lot of
people would be like hey this was a lot
of fun but I don't see it as a match and
then the response would be well I didn't
we went on one date you don't have to
tell me you don't to dump me and you're
like well what do I do
it's a lose-lose so at least if you
ghost here don't get yelled at exactly
so we're all just in fear of of being
that person that's bad guy bad no one
and actually breaking up with someone is
worse than being broken
I completely agree I hey it's the reason
90% of us try to get the person to dump
us before we dump them yeah and he
wouldn't like subconsciously to yeah
you're just like oh I'll act like a dick
and I'll act weird for a couple weeks
then they'll get rid of me so I don't
have to do that and I get to like be sad
and be a victim and people feel sorry
for me and the whole brunch will come
over and hug you to death and say he was
a loser anyways you know like that's it
and you know what here's the problem the
age at first marriage so people used to
get married for years earlier than they
do now
nobody's average age now I don't know
the number I'm Diana Ross on this I
don't know a lot of stuff on this but I
do know that the average age where
people have gotten married in the
country this isn't just New York is four
years older than it was ten or twelve
years ago that is a lot of movement for
an average yeah for the country that's a
big move so now we have let's so let's
call it that we have four extra years to
be a [ __ ] to somebody and that
stinks because our parents never really
had it that sucks yeah because we're
meeting a lot of nice people and nice
people are different than the one that's
nice for me so we're all ending
relationships with perfectly great
people who are perfect for somebody but
for no reason at all other than I don't
feel it yeah and it's like most all of
us would much rather walk in on our
significant other [ __ ] someone else
so that we can go good at least I know
no but when you have to break up with
someone and you don't know
reason to bring up with them are
legitimate deal-breakers sure it's just
your thing and then you have your single
friend that looks at you and goes they
were great
and it's a gift for you you didn't live
with them you didn't have to see them on
a daily basis right so and also like I
have a lot of exes out there that you
know I've dated a lot of women I'm sure
I have nothing bad to say about those
people those were the hardest ones right
to get over because you go what am i
throwing away a good hand for a hand
that I don't even know if I'm gonna get
a better than the hand is worth two in
the bus this is right so I I understand
why people ghost because it's tough to
be mean to someone that you actually
like but not enough you know what's
harder well you know how hard is it to
look someone in the eye and go I've
enjoyed being with you I've enjoyed
[ __ ] you I don't want to do that
anymore you know that's hard yeah well
yeah and it's not you it's just that
this man it's and you used to be that
it's like it's not you it's me yeah
that's not what it is it's not you it's
the match yeah and that so we have to
take these things less personal and it's
it's very difficult ghosting though
sucks I think when you've been ghosted
it kind of feels like you showed up to
someone's house to go play and they know
you're like knocking at the door and
like they're the hole all your friends
are upstairs being like shh shh don't
say anything yeah this guy's obsessed
with me and it's like well thank you so
much for being here I'm running so late
for what I have to do today please
please please I'd love to where can
everyone follow you keep up with you and
get more premium advice that Jared freed
on instagram at Jared freed on Instagram
the you up podcast every Wednesday we at
5 o'clock so you can subscribe it's
called the UI podcast since with betches
but my Instagram is kind of the hub of
the wheel that's where I put everything
out from at Jared freed and I put up
dating app conversations I put up yeah
look I act like I make myself the the
the joke and then I do I do the bat I
know you guys love The Bachelor yes I'm
a huge national fan what do you think
about caffeine called in the most
annoying Instagram couple in the history
of Instagram couples but I'm happy for
them I think I think they're the right
match for each other
I met Colton Colton couldn't have been a
nicer guy I would call him a mensch for
our Jewish people out there he did my
podcast actually and before he came out
of the bachelor Oh before he was the
bachelor yeah
oh wow just so interesting so we I had
him on a live podcast when I was in
Denver he couldn't have been nicer
brought me a bottle of wine I like gave
him a crumpled-up $50 abilities I give
it to my charity I'm like oh mama loser
is a really good guy
I loved him as a chair I'm happy for him
I just want happiness for him
they'll be they're made for each other
it feels right I mean they are annoying
on Instagram I've said that they're
posting some like weird not weird stuff
but like it's not like super premium and
it's like they could you be doing better
I feel you know he's acting like a 16
year old who just lost his virginity
you know oh guess what so I think I'm
happy for him I don't know you know
Hanna what do you think of the Maddox
right what do you think of the choice
I'm not here for it not here at all like
I didn't have a good Jen have a good
first no first impression they will edit
and melt Koecher and by the end everyone
will love her and forget everything but
I'm just not in the mood to be patient
you know Taoiseach was the choice to me
because she was like the fun personality
right and she had a story she was
cheated on she's got an ass he's really
looking for a serious relationship I
could have also gone for Hannah gee I
feel like there are so much more there
that we didn't get to know and she's
actually a more like serious and and has
more personality than we expected from
her just because she's so just to see
Hannah jeez mom rap again that's all we
wanted right
but Hannah B I
it was a tough watch that first but I
hasn't got like he watches everything
with me something that certain he
happened to watch the last episode
because I was adamant about watching it
live because I could yeah and so was the
only episode he watched after the final
Griffith Hannity and he
in physical pain like and it was like
the worst introduction to the bachelor
because he's like how can you watch it
no it's not always like that everything
her whole thing was everything she every
time she spoke it was like it was being
ripped from her from within her it was
excruciating I it was just like
Hanabi just say what you want to say
like and you could tell she's nervous
it's the first time I'm a huge fan of
the the franchise I mean if you go to my
Instagram I have part 1 & 2 of the
finale I did ice cream over the TV while
I watch it and I do live stories so I
have live stories it's like two parts of
my highlights if you want to go check it
out at Jared freed but I loved watching
The Bachelor because I like I like it
because on a big scale like you're your
husband the way he's looking at it he's
looking at it from the wide angle where
it is a stupid show right 30 women 30
men go for one guy but if you go to the
small moments I mean especially Calton
getting dumped by Cassie like that was a
real dump it uh-huh
that's how all of us have dumped some
huh all of us have looked at someone
going I love you and then going but like
not in love with you exactly that
statement is such [ __ ] anyways what
salud she was trying that she just fell
in love with him yesterday and now isn't
in love with him it felt like a lot of
excuses to not half today because she
was like well what about these other
people it's like you know when you're
like trying to be with someone who
doesn't want to be with you and you're
like you're you're totally just being
honest you're like wait a minute we can
date and then we can figure it out and
he's like everything yeah and then she
goes well you missing out on marriage
he's like he's like I'm what do you do
am I crazy what are you talking about no
you just don't want to be with this
person but it did feel like I like that
they're giving it a shot yeah I hope it
works out because I like Colton a lot I
don't you know Cassie I don't know but
I'm like what they're doing now is what
she wanted out of the bachelor but
really didn't think that that was
possible where it's like they just date
and live in LA
and like go to Coachella and hang out
with her sister be young and be cute and
fun and on Instagram and like they have
that and they think it's possible that
it can become something more serious I
am totally with you and also the best
part about their Instagram and start to
keep us here I got to go to the the
sister poking her head into every story
is the best yeah her sister is so
beautiful then she dates that guy he was
to date that left thorn and like their
own musician right yeah Greg I just
think it's funny that she's like and I'm
here to check out my Instagram tag me
I'm really close to following her she
post some good [ __ ] do you see them I've
been me fair slay anyway thank you so
much pleasure to me at least follow me
at Jackie Oh problems I will be back
tomorrow with Justin Sylvester from
daily pop aka the lady sitter we are
starting later tomorrow to accommodate
his schedule so we will start live at
noon tomorrow so I can sleep in a little
bit and look good I did get that sleep
that's the most important part of life I
think anyways have a great day everyone
thank you so much thank you for having
me
you